So brother, whatever you have noticed here,
this is a physics phenomenon that has happened under Bernoulli's theorem.
Now Bernoulli's theorem says
that in any moving fluid, the
value of pressure p 1/2 ro v s + roz
always remains constant.  And if
we apply the meaning of this theorem in this situation, then we
notice that
because there is too much air outside, hence 1/2 Rovi
score becomes very high and the value of pressure
decreases and the same thing happens
inside the house.  If applied, because the velocity is
next to zero, the half row square becomes
very low and the pressure is very high, so
all in all the pressure inside the house is very high
and the pressure outside the house is very high.
Drawstring
Sept. If you guys like it then it is good.  If you like this
video then subscribe to this channel immediately.